greetings everyone this is rob sanders
from simply learn and today we're going
to talk about
how to get traffic to your website so
thank you for joining and let's get
started
before i tell you how to bring traffic
to your website let me tell you
why this is so important okay why do we
want to bring users to our website
i mean it has to be on equal ground as
web development
and design is somebody who goes to your
site
and then does something when they get to
your site so you have users and
when those users get to your site
they're generating page views and
traffic
and you want to turn that traffic into
engagement
okay so each page's traffic is
configured independently
of all their pages so when you go when
somebody goes to your website
they look at a page that's a page view
and certain pages on your website you
want to turn that page view into a
conversion okay whether that be
you know looking at a video or
purchasing something
so think of these pages on your website
as salespeople they're trying to convert
visitors who come to your website but
first we need to get the visitors to
your website
so when you get visitors to your website
again you can
generate sales which means revenue or
you can increase brand awareness or you
can earn revenue through
sponsored posts and advertisements so if
you have for example a lot of content on
your website
you can turn that in to revenue by
hosting ads on your website so when
somebody clicks on that ad
you're going to earn a percentage of
that click okay what that click is worth
so having a website means a lot of good
things for you
but first you got to get the traffic
there and so what we're going to do is
we're going to tell you
how to drive traffic to your website so
there's lots of different ways
in which you can bring traffic to your
website well the first is paid
advertising
so paying to advertise your products
services with ads is one of the easiest
ways
to drive traffic to your website so some
of the options available
are search ads social media ads or
display ads
so search ads are ads that are displayed
in the search
engine results so when a user types in a
keyword
query you want your ad to show up based
on that keyword query
okay so an example is digital marketing
course
somebody types in digital marketing
course and simply learn
is the first app that shows up how do we
know it's an ad because
you can see the word ad next to the
domain
so when somebody clicks on that link
simply learn
is going to pay google so that's how
search advertising works
okay the next is social so social media
marketing involves
increasing traffic or engagement or
brand awareness a lot of different
strategies
but you're instead of doing this on
search you're doing it on a social media
platform
okay so for example you can advertise
on any particular platform and the way
you advertise
could be with an image it could be with
a video so
in this case you could see cobreo
is doing a sponsored ad here how to
succeed with google ads
and then another form of advertising is
display so display means creating ads
that are placed on specific websites
so with display unlike search you have a
choice
in the ad format with search you only
have text ads
but with display you have text edge
image ads
rich media ads video ads so you have
lots of different
options in which you can advertise on
other websites
so the idea here is to get your ad in
front of the right audience when they
could see
your display banner your banner ad then
it's going to be more visual more
appealing generate some brand
interest and hopefully you can get
somebody to click on that ad
and over to your website so that's paid
advertising again through search through
social through display but
you can also promote your site on social
media so once your content has gone
live you could take advantage of
different social media platforms
i mean it really depends on what you're
trying to promote
because what you're trying to promote
needs to align with the appropriate
social media platform
so facebook is best suited for
industries like food and beverages and
news and media
and if you're selling a product so you
fall into one of those categories and
facebook could be the right platform for
you
if you're involved in again beauty or
food and beverage or e-commerce then you
can also
leverage instagram which is part of
facebook's ecosystem
so if you advertise on facebook you can
also advertise on instagram
and or instagram so it doesn't have to
be and
facebook and instagram it could be
facebook or instagram you also have
linkedin as a platform linkedin is great
for b2b
so if you're trying to promote industry
news or
or tips and best practices or job
postings
then linkedin is the place for you it's
a b2b platform
it's great for targeting specific
industries targeting specific job levels
or job descriptions okay so linkedin
is great if you're into b2b focusing on
the business side of it
so you also have youtube now youtube is
part of google's ecosystem
youtube is a video platform okay so
it's great if you're trying to promote
gaming or entertainment
if you're a vlogger okay so youtube's a
great way
to promote your site uh by getting your
product out there in the form of a video
and then you have twitter twitter to me
encompasses a lot of different
industries
beauty and fitness news and media
entertainment
okay you have limited number of
characters but
a lot of people are active on twitter
and it's a great way to generate some
awareness and get some clicks over to
your website so these are just some of
the most
popular social media platforms of course
there are plenty more
out there the third way in which you can
drive traffic to your site is guest post
blogging so most of you already know
what blogging's all about
well if you're blogging for your own
site you can jump on somebody else's
site
and blog on their behalf so having the
opportunity to guest post on another
website can be very helpful
because one that other blog could have
lots of traffic
and have a a well-known brand so if
you're blogging
on another blog it's gonna build your
brand awareness and potentially increase
traffic to your blog or website so it
exposes
to you to targeted traffic so
if you're going to guest blog guest blog
on a site that's very
relevant to your business or industry
that way you're targeting the right
audience
okay you can expand your personal
network so
getting yourself out there getting your
brand out there in front of a different
audience
and then obviously for service because
it generates a backlink so serps
search engine ranking pages means that
hey
if you want to rank organically you're
going to have to generate
some backlinks so guest blogging is a
way to generate some back links
to your site and an effect that's going
to help you
get your pages ranked higher because
google is going to recognize the
relationship
from one blog to your blog and build up
your relevancy
so some other benefits here to guest
blogging
is you can grow your social media
following because you can then
promote that on social media that you're
guest blogging
okay again you can improve your online
authority okay
because when you're guest blogging and
you have recognition on that guest blog
if it's a popular blog then it's
going to help your domain and page
authority for seo
and then the end result is going to
improve your backlink score
so a lot of benefits to guest blogging
to me at the end of the day it's just
about
reaching out to your audience using
another platform to do that
in the form of a blog and the results of
that is going to mean
more brand awareness for you and turning
that traffic
from that other blog into qualified
leads
so you can also interview industry
thought leader so that's another way an
interesting way to generate traffic to
your site so reaching out to
thought leaders for interviews okay
could generate some credibility
for you and the other person so it's
reciprocal so it means that you're
active
in the industry that you're in and it
allows you to engage with other
leaders in the industry and the indirect
net result of that could be increased
traffic because if you do the interview
and you record it or if it's via video
then you can obviously post it on other
platforms
and that could in turn drive traffic to
your website
obviously just like guest blogging it's
going to
increase your reach so getting yourself
out there if nobody knows who your brand
is
and they know who the thought leaders
are and they say you're interviewing the
thought leaders
then that's going to put you in front of
these people
and so it's going to increase your reach
another way
to drive traffic to your website is just
to make sure your website's responsive
and what do we mean by response of well
we mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows
shrinks enlarges or moves content
so that it conforms to the browser
that that person's looking at on your
web for your website
so if somebody's looking on mobile at
your website you want to make sure that
your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive
and so is content arranged based on
importance
okay does it work across different
browsers on different devices
and do the images text and everything
else align
just like it does on desktop so there
are plenty of tools out there on the web
all you need to do is just do a search
for you know check my website for
responsiveness
you know so you you can use plenty of
tools to check to see if your website
is responsive towards multiple devices
why is that important because if
somebody goes to your website via mobile
and your site doesn't align properly or
the content's all stretched out
and somebody has to maneuver their
browser just to see your website
then chances are they're not going to
come back chances are they're not going
to convert
okay so you want to be able to revise
your device browser combinations you
want to make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts
make sure they look good and then you
also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile
are they going to navigate just as easy
as they can on desktop
and if you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed
so that way when somebody's looking at
your website they're not getting
interfered with
on mobile and then of course you want to
make sure that these pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop
as they should on mobile and vice versa
so this should not take a long time to
load
so moving on from responsiveness on
mobile to
building a brand community so brand
community refers to a group of people
who identify your brand
and use your brand as a platform to
exchange ideas and contribute
content some advantages of having a
brand community are
promoting brand evangelism and loyalty
it can be a source of feedback loyalty
and ideas
so build a community build a brand
community
who you know identify with you okay so
continue to
you know treat these people as loyal
customers
okay maybe give them a promotion uh to
use
specifically just for them that they can
use on your website or talk
directly to them because you know that
they're
followers their repeat customers they
purchase for you multiple times
so talk to them differently as well you
know who these people
are and that's what building a brand's
all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and identify people who identify
with your brand
and messaging and talking to them as if
they're part of your own community
your own family so you can use user
generated content
that provides future marketing
strategies so the feedback you get from
your own community
could be in turn used to promote or used
in
future marketing strategies i.e
advertising i.e
post on social it can also provide pr
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on
the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is
should be able to identify with your
audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become
part of a community these are group of
people who identify with you
what you're trying to sell what your
cause is what your mission statement is
what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately
give them the what they deserve the
respect and loyalty that they deserve as
well because they're
communicating and they're following you
as a brand so
the next thing you could do to drive
traffic is be active in the comment
section
so engage in relevant and thought
provoking conversations
on other blogs and sites it doesn't
necessarily have to be another
blog per se it could be other sites like
reddit
or quora or media sites that have a lot
of content
that are broken out by industry that
allow you to engage in conversation
allow you to either upvote or share or
respond
okay so be active because when you're
active people are going to see
that hey you're a leader in the industry
you know what you're talking about
you have some some brand equity you have
some thought and some knowledge on the
specific
topic and subject so it just puts you in
a better light when you can respond and
be active
on these different platforms okay let's
turn our attention to
search engine optimization also known as
seo
or organic search so in order to drive
traffic to your site
you're going to have to implement an seo
strategy
why do you want to implement an seo
strategy because it can help you improve
your
overall search ability and visibility on
search engines
and obviously that comes with advantages
one of those advantages is obviously
more
traffic to the site search is still king
in terms of
volumes of people using search on a
daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found
it also builds trust and credibility
because still a majority of the people
who do a search click on an organic
search listing
and so if you're found organically and
you're ranked number one
then chances are somebody's going to
click
on your listing and it provides
increased engagement and traffic
and so what that means is more traffic
more engagement
an engagement is something you define it
could be again a download of a
document or the clicking on the play
button of a video
or or submitting a form or signing up
for a newsletter
or calling these are all forms of
engagement so
the the amount of traffic you drive from
organic
search to your website is only going to
improve
engagement okay so you can also provide
an
improved user experience and what do we
mean by that well
if you're getting lots of traffic from
organic
search you have a really good
opportunity to do a b testing
and when you do a b testing you can
improve user experience meaning you're
showing one variation against the other
from people coming from organic search
and so
this is helpful and that you know if
you're running an a b
test the variation has a chance to
improve
or outperform the original and if it
outperforms the original you're
improving user experience
and then it helps target quality traffic
so seo to me
or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting
somebody halfway you're you're
addressing what they're looking for
so somebody's looking for pair of red
women's nike shoes the 2019 model
and you have that particular product to
offer well
you have a chance of showing up via
organic search somebody types in
new women's red nike shoes size
whatever at the year 2019 model
then of course they're gonna probably
likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and that goes with any keyword any
industry any business any segment
any type of product you're selling
so again you have a chance to really be
visible
for what people are looking for and so
that's the beauty of search engine
optimization you have a really good
opportunity here
to meet people halfway to drive quality
traffic
to get them to enjoy a good user
experience
all the while generating engagement and
along with seo we want to be able to
build backlinks so
seo is a two-pronged approach meaning
you have two strategies in one on page
and off page
and so off page involves backlinking so
backlinks are just
links that direct users from other
websites to your own website
so with that inherently it's going to
drive traffic
qualified traffic to your website
because if somebody's on a relevant
website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning
they're going to be relevant and so back
linking because it's an off page
strategy why is it an off-page seo
strategy because
if google crawls that other site that
has a link to you
then that's going to give you credit
because google say hey this site's
getting some
links from some relevant sites we must
think they're relevant and therefore
we're going to trust this site so by
google
trusting your site it's going to improve
your organic ranking
and with the organic rankings being
improved
meaning it's going to mean faster
indexing
so what does that mean so you want to be
indexed by the search engines
and so the quicker google can find your
pages even if it's on somebody else's
site
then that means they're going to follow
that link go to that page on your site
and take that page back to their servers
to be indexed
okay so the quicker you can get indexed
the quicker you get found and then it
helps with referral traffic so
again we noticed that our efforts are on
seo organic search
but if you're getting traffic from
another website hey that still counts
that's referral traffic okay so that's a
side advantage to having backlinks
is good traffic from other sites okay so
those
those are inherently the some of the
reasons to do backlinking okay
never hurts i mean there's brand
awareness reasons to being on other
sites as well
there's industry leadership meaning if
you you post content on reddit
okay you're coming across as an industry
leader but yet generating a backlink
which helps with seo and referral
traffic so there's a lot of benefits to
building
backlinks and the opposite of backlinks
are internal links
so you want to do internal linking and
that just means connecting one page on
your site to another
and why is that beneficial because it
can help direct
visitors to other pages they wouldn't
normally otherwise
find via your navigation so if you're
active on a blog
don't be afraid to include multiple
internal links
you want to move people through your
site you want the flow of traffic
to go from one page to another to
another and so when you do internal
linking
just like with backlinks it's going to
improve the indexing of your website
google is going to
follow those links and index those pages
and google does give
credit from an seo perspective from an
internal linking perspective so
if one page is linked to another and
that page has
really good relevance in the eyes of
google then the other page is probably
going to benefit from that
the other reason you want to do internal
linking again you want to move people
from your one page of your site to the
other
and when you do that it's going to
reduce bounce rates so bounce rate is
simply
the rate at which people land on a page
and then leave
so if i have 100 people land on my
homepage and only one person went to
another page and the other 99 left the
site
then that's a 99 bounce rate so
by putting internal links in place
you're helping people move from one page
to the other
and thus reducing the bounce rate and
that's what you want you want to keep
people on your site you want to be
greedy it also drives
traffic to older posts so again when we
say older posts we're really referring
to blog posts so if you have
a relevant blog post and you're writing
a new blog post
then link the two together if it's
relevant link it i don't you know
regardless of how old it is
you know you want to show google that
these older blog posts just because they
were written a year ago doesn't mean
they're outdated
and old-fashioned okay or useless you
want to keep them alive by linking to
them
so to me that's a good strategy for
internal linking
link to older blog posts you know show
people you're an industry expert you've
been doing this for a while
and then you have lots of content to
share okay so
the longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more
likely it is they're going to engage and
convert and some other inherent benefits
improves page rank so what we mean by
pagerank is simply just
a rank that google gives pages so the
more internal linking you have
the better off you are and then it helps
spread link juice
across websites and we'll maybe buy link
juice again
just like backlinking it builds
relevancy so
just keep all these inherent benefits in
mind to internal linking
the end result is keeping the flow of
traffic on your site
and all these other benefits will fall
into place okay
so another way in which you can really
hone in on traffic to your website is
long tail keywords
and long tail keywords to me are more
than just one
or two keyword phrases okay so they're
usually three or longer
keywords in a phrase okay so long tail
keywords
really nowadays account for most web
searches people
really take the time to even post
questions as a search query
say likely somebody it's unlikely
somebody's going to go into search and
just type in the word shoes
they might type in red shoes but that's
unlikely what they're probably going to
type in
is you know red nike
running shoes 2019 or some variation of
that okay that's a long tail keyword
and some of the advantages of using long
tail keywords
to be found for are less competition so
if you're using broad keywords like
red shoes then who doesn't want to be
found for red shoes
well you don't necessarily you don't
want to be found for red shoes because
it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
red shoes
it could be running shoes it could be
work shoes it could be
you know boots it could be slippers okay
it's too bright so long tail keywords
help narrow it in
and the more narrow and focused the
keyword is the less competition it's
going to have
and when something's not competitive in
the form of a keyword
then that means your chances of ranking
for that keyword are going to be greater
and the chance of you ranking faster are
going to be greater and then of course
if somebody's looking for exactly what
you have to offer
then you have a higher chance to convert
that person so if you have exactly those
2019
red nike women's running shoes and
somebody does a search for that and
that's a long tail keyword and they
click on your organic listing
if you have the right price then they're
probably going to convert
so you have a really good chance of
converting somebody using long tail
keywords
so my point here is if you're looking
for keywords to use
focus on longer tail don't focus on one
or two keyword phrases
what it also does is it brings targeted
traffic so even if somebody doesn't
convert
hey they could be back because it's
exactly what they're looking for
and if you're focusing on longer tail
keywords like i just mentioned stay away
from the shorter ones it's just
easier to optimize your page for seo
so remember seo is a two pronged
approach on page and off page
we talked about off page with internal
linking and backlinks
on page is all about making sure those
keywords you choose
are integrated in with the page you want
to be found for
and so if you're using a long tail
keyword it's just easy to work that
keyword in
so it enables easier on-page
optimization
okay let's switch away from seo to email
marketing so
let's focus on email marketing as a form
or method of driving
traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long
time in terms of digital marketing why
because it provides an effective way to
convert leads into sales
why because you can send personalized
emails to a target audience
so when you send an email to somebody on
a regular basis
you know who that person is so what are
you doing in the email
you're writing a specific message to
that person well email marketing is the
same thing
except you're just sending an email to a
larger group of people and
when you send an email to a larger group
of people you're still
going to personalize the message right
you're not going to send a generic email
to
1 000 people okay nobody's going to do
that so make sure your email is targeted
if it's targeted
it can be cost effective why because
sending large
amounts of emails or let's just say an
email to a large amount of people or a
large group of people
is going to be cost effective it's not
cost per click
you know it's not cost per open okay so
email usually
depending on the the email provider
you're using
really is a flat fee so it just really
depends on how many emails you're
sending
or how how many people you're sending
the email to as well
so but email generally tends to be more
cost effective than other forms of
marketing
so look at the email content provider
you're using
and just get a sense of what they charge
but if you look at it and do a
comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords
so email marketing is also time saving
okay meaning
it's a one-time thing and done so once
you send the email
it's just a matter of you know watching
and looking at the metrics and learning
what's going on
so you don't make the same mistakes
again but it is time
conducive meaning you send out one email
and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns
and it provides real-time marketing so
when you do send the email
more than likely a majority of the
people on day one or the day you send
the email
are gonna be able to view it open it
click on some of the links and convert
so
that's normally what happens an email
majority of the people
open it on day one and it kind of tails
off from there so think about it as real
time
so when you send that email and if you
have a thousand people on your email
recipient list
break it up send the first 500 first
with a different subject line
and then you can see the data come in
and if you don't see the good results
from the subject line or the body of the
email or
you know the page you're going to then
make adjustments before you send the
other
email to the next 500. so that's a great
thing about emails you can break up the
email
into two groups the first group and then
the second group with different subject
lines and you can probably
send them a little bit of time apart
that way you can learn from the first
email
because with email you are generally
going to get results right away
okay within the first 24 hours so that's
a great thing about email
okay so the other thing about email it's
less intrusive
so normally people who are going to get
the email
are the ones who sign up for the email
so they're almost expecting your email
so when they get your email again as
long as you're not sending an email on a
daily basis
normally most companies send it monthly
or bi-weekly
it's not going to be as intrusive okay
and then it also helps build credibility
increased visibility
and brand awareness meaning you're going
to build your brand in that email
you're going to put content in that
email that's going to
show off your credibility meaning you
could put some testimonials in the email
you can put some good affiliations you
can put a good article
to an industry article you just wrote so
email
is going to inherently continue to build
brand awareness for you
okay and it's an easy way to track roi
so if your
e-commerce it's pretty clear you send
the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something
it's easily trackable because you could
track it right from that email
so one thing i want to say there is just
if you do send an email
make sure you're tracking that campaign
and you want to be able to use an
analytics program like google analytics
if you use google analytics you're going
to be able to track when you send the
email
who clicks on it and who converts so you
want to be able to measure an roi for
these emails and you can
and that's the beauty of email marketing
okay let's move away from email
marketing to webinars so webinars
great method for effective social media
promotion
it's a great way to bring traffic to
your website so
why do we recommend webinars well
because it provides direct
content contact within your target group
what do we mean by contact with your
target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are
interested in your product or service so
if you have a facebook community you
could do a facebook live event
or you could do a youtube or you know
you can even
set up a webinar on another platform but
promote it on social media
and if you're pronouncing something on
social media you're probably promoting
it to people who are already
following you or like you and so that's
what we mean by direct
contact with your target group so you're
going to be able to create a webinar and
talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness
and credibility and the great thing
about webinars is you don't need some
fancy software
i mean i'm talking to you on a webinar
right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all
and that's all built in with software so
there's plenty of software out there
that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots
of opportunities in software so and a
lot of them are very cost effective so
if you want to build uh create a webinar
you can do that
by spending very little money and
webinars again
allow you to talk to your targeted group
your community
maybe prospective clients it helps build
credibility
and in effect drive traffic to your
website and when somebody does attend
a webinar they're likely going to be
highly engaged
because you're inviting them they're
going to opt
into the webinar and the great thing
about webinars is even if they don't
attend the webinar the day you have it
it's going to be recorded
so they can always go back and watch it
so whoever watches the webinar
is going to be engaged because it's
going to be a topic they're interested
in
and then users are likely to become
prospective customers so
having a webinar talking about something
inherently
interesting to maybe a larger group of
people
you can promote that on social media and
potentially get prospective customers to
sign up and watch the webinar and if you
do
they're going to be engaged and then
take the next step oh i like what this
guy
this person has to say they seem to be
credible
i like their personality i like their
brand i like their product
i'm gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull
in more people as well as just your
community because you can promote the
webinar
and you can promote it in advance and
you can leverage social media for that
okay so something related to webinars
incorporating video content
so videos have been proven to be a
really good way to attract new visitors
and it just it makes your website very
engaging when you have videos
on your website as well so if you create
video you have an
opportunity to post it on various video
platforms like
youtube or vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or
just embedded in a blog post or embedded
in a facebook post
or a tweet okay so you can do a lot with
video
and having video on your site is going
to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen
that's going to lead to increased
conversions in sales or
roi or just like we mentioned the
webinar
can help build trust with your audience
even that webinar you could post
on your website so you want people to
engage
by watching this video they watch the
video they're going to gain trust in you
because you're talking directly
to that person that user that audience
that visitor to your website
and when you get built trust it's going
to increase engagement
and that's the beauty of video unlike
text or imagery
videos really do engage with the
audience and so the more video
you could do the better off you are
because again you can leverage social
to draw attention to your brand and
product and service
and then you can have that video on your
website to increase
engagement which in turn increases
conversions and sales
and improves roi so always think video
there's plenty of video software out
there that you can leverage
and the great thing about video 2 is hey
most people are using mobile phones
these days
smart phones and so video works just as
well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging
regardless of what device somebody uses
and then of course if they're watching
the video
on facebook or youtube then chances are
they're going to
share that particular video which is
going to bode well for your brand and
traffic
okay so video if somebody likes a video
it's very easy to share video
especially from a mobile phone so
youtube just makes it so
easy to share or like or subscribe to a
channel
it just it becomes that much easier
things can go viral
and chances of them going viral video
are going to be greater okay so
other ways to drive traffic to your
website is submit your content to
content
aggregators so what's a content
aggregator well a content aggregator is
like
reddit that provides a great platform
for you to post your content
so that's what a content aggregator is
really a site like reddit or medium or
quora
where you could post content to a large
number of people
okay so with reddit people are either
going to upvote it or downvote it so the
more
upvotes you get or thumbs up or likes
or people who encourage that content the
more
of a chance it has to be found and so
first thing out of the gate if you do
provide content to a content aggregator
like
reddit make sure it's good quality
content that's interesting
and that should be a case the case
across the board whether it's a
social post or blog post make sure the
content's unique
professional and interesting and then if
you do say put something on medium or
you do
put something on cora and it is
professional and interesting and
thought-provoking
then people are going to react to it and
then that again
could lead to traffic but even if it
doesn't lead to traffic
it helps build brand awareness so if you
have content
just like videos leverage it put the
content out there
and when you put content out there it's
only gonna especially if it's good
content but
it's gonna put you in a good light so
don't be afraid to share your content on
the likes
of reddit or medium or core or some of
these other
content aggregator websites because good
things are only going to happen
and again referral traffic seo
brand awareness conversions so all these
are inherent
benefits of just sharing your content
okay and then
finally we want to learn from analytics
okay so what do i mean learning from
analytics so
there are plenty of analytics platforms
out there one of the most popular is
google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with google analytics
so all you have to do is just go to
google analytics via search
sign up add the analytics code to your
website and while
they're doing all the heavy lifting
they're going to track traffic
coming your website and not only they're
going to track traffic
but they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it google analytics is
hey you can figure out where users are
coming from are they coming from that
email campaign that i
sent out to a thousand people are they
coming from youtube
based on that video i posted or they
coming from reddit based on the content
i just posted there
or they coming from organic search it is
so google analytics can help us
understand how much traffic we're
getting from organic search
so to help us measure our seo efforts
and then with google analytics you could
segment so we could segment
by mobile we can segment by desktop
returning user new user
by campaign by page by language by
city by region i mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is
breaking up the entire group of people
who come to your website into different
segments
based on what you want to see so
if you want to look at you know females
between the ages of 18 to 24 who come
from mobile
via organic search that's a segment and
you can look at that
information in analytics if that's your
target audience
then you could see how they're
performing okay so anal there are a lot
of benefits to google analytics
definitely want to take advantage of
segmenting
in google analytics you could look at
your competition so there's a
benchmarking report
the great thing about google analytics
you can also look at content
and how your content is performing when
somebody
lands on your website are they what page
are they spending time on
what page are they engaging on the most
okay what pages have the highest bounce
rate or the lowest time on page
so you can really determine what pages
work best
and then of course the end result in
analyzing all this data
is you want to be able to fine-tune your
website so take
advantage of the data that google
analytics or
any other analytics platform is giving
you by learning
once you learn what's going on with your
website you can make adjustments
to your website to improve user
experience
okay so we went over a lot of different
ways to drive traffic
okay you can incorporate all this to
your website immediately
if you have any questions feel free to
comment below
ask questions we went over a lot of
different ways to drive traffic
so expect some questions you can also go
to simplylearn.com for more information
so thank you appreciate it and look
forward to seeing you in the future
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here